my name causes national security alerts
what does yours do Mohammad youssuf
Abdulazeez chose this quote for his high
school yearbook and years later he did
in fact cause a major security alert in
Chattanooga Tennessee last week Abdul
Aziz opened fire at a military
recruiting center and then drove to a
local Navy Support Center killing five
American servicemen as his name was
released after he died in the shooting
authorities scrambled to find a link to
an extremist group we are conducting
this as a an act of domestic terrorism
while his attack may fit the ISIS mold
reports so far indicate that he acted
alone but it hasn't stopped lawmakers
and pundits from jumping to immediate
conclusions my judgment in my experience
is this there was an isis-inspired
attack this is terrorism the suspected
shooter Muhammad Abdul Aziz a devout
Muslim they're here on American soil to
kill us and they're killing us what we
do know is that Abdul Aziz had trouble
holding down a job a few months back he
was fired for failing a drug test and he
was arrested for driving under the
influence his family says he struggled
with depression and substance abuse they
say he was first treated by a
psychiatrist when he was about 12 years
old when asked in an interview with CNN
whether he followed Isis a friend of
Abdul Aziz had this response What did he
say man it was a stupid group and it was
completely guessing his own
the feds are now poring over some of
Abdul Aziz his scribbled notes that
reportedly reflect some anti-american
sentiment mostly however they show that
he was suicidal but not everyone who
battles depression goes on a shooting
rampage and there's a concerning pattern
here beyond if Abdul Aziz was mentally
ill the US military was still his target
and nearly a third of the 119 Americans
accused of plotting an attack inside the
u.s. since 9/11 planned to attack
military targets we don't even know all
the details behind the attack in
Chattanooga but we do know that al Qaeda
and ISIL have encouraged attacks on
American soil including against our
service members whether motivated by
religious extremism white supremacy
mental illness or
backlash to US militarism when and how
we draw these conclusions about these
kinds of attacks is a bigger question
one we don't always get right
immediately